okay welcome back everyone
so a little bit about we're going to
proceed now we're going to have
another talk using embeddings and deep
neural networks for demand forecasting
and after that we have so far as I know
one lightning talk if you have another
lightning talk now is the time to
notify us
and yes after the lightning talks we
will end the streaming for everyone who
joined online and
um we can after lightning talks we can
have more beers downstairs they will be
there at the same place where we just
had the pizza and we can like just have
some more drinks and chat and network
and so yeah please a warm welcome to
Daniel and Martin
[Applause]
thank you thank you for having us
um so I'll start a bit with uh with some
background so Martin and myself both
studied physics and
um uh more than 10 years part of luyanda
um and uh blue yonder for everyone to
know it's a supply chain software
company so you see here the biggest
pillars of things that the company is
doing in Supply sales of uh supply chain
software and we are working in demand
planning segment and they're especially
on Luminate demand Edge the latest
demand forecasting engine that the
company has
so limited demand Edge
is a probabilistic demand forecasting
engine
which works for our customers which are
usually retailers Grocers or
or other manufacturers or other Goods
that they are selling to their customers
and they they give us the data
we cross correlate that use our
algorithm so we will come to the
algorithmic part in a minute
and then we output a probability density
function
just not just the point mean regression
estimate but the whole density function
which then allows the further algorithms
to optimize on cost functions
for example I don't know if you are
selling vegetables how much do you
do you order that it's not perishing too
much and that people are not sitting in
your store and are not having a broccoli
any longer so that's the typical use
case so a very brief
overview on the history what we used
um so basically
we had a first algorithm called neural
base was founded in the 90s was a
physics collaboration
because the founder of the company a
physics Professor did that together with
his colleagues in CERN
and then
um in 2013 we basically
changed from the very broad neurobase
to an open source algorithm cyclic
boosting which we developed in-house and
open source later
um
and which is basically able when you
focus on specific data sets that you can
Define very clear interactions and which
allows you to model data problems very
specifically and very rigidly
and um yeah uh has has the advantages so
everyone welcome to um look at that on
GitHub
in 21
um we released an update that we were
building for some time before that
um that allowed us to go back from local
so basically in memory calculation to
um what we call Global so basically on
the whole data set
at once which was necessary because we
had bigger and bigger customers and thus
needed something to scale out
and the latest addition which we the
talk is basically about
is what we call them deep meta learning
it's also a global principle where we
will see in the talk what what that
means about and we have some ideas
already for the future uh what will come
after that so why already two years
later something new so basically it's
not only about the technical performance
but rather on scaling out to more and
more customers so like um
if the feature engineering that is still
required in our current and that's is
basically limiting the speed which we
with which we can bring in new customers
which have different data sets and
basically that's also like what Gail uh
talked about
um in the previous talk that
um you need something to represent how
the data looks like so and basically
that's where our current anzas comes in
we might be looking at Transformers in
the future so for the next part
um Martin will come up and talk about
what we basically did in the engineering
uh to yeah to work on that and that's
yeah hi and thanks for the introduction
Daniel
um yeah I will talk a bit about the the
model that we that we currently are
taking live or having live for our
customers
so um as Daniel mentioned or we have
several
um
columns that the model needs to take
into account like the product
identification code the brand of the
product the product groups
and um
these are just a few so we also have
weather data location data promotional
data price data and so on
and one thing that our customers want is
interpretability of the prediction
so you see that our demand forecast
is a sum of of different factors
and these factors map more or less to
the input features so the promo Factor
gives you an indication how the demand
varies with promotional changes so if
the product is in promotion or not
and um
what uh what we now have is so we we
plug in our raw features that I just
mentioned
and the Deep meta learning does then
learn representations of these inputs
for example out of all these product
influences or product features we learn
product meta features
and these are then combined in the
connectors to to have
interactions with for example with
promotions or so on
so this is a
before in the generalized additive model
that Daniel mentioned we had to write
down all the features and all the
interactions manually so not not like in
in a decision tree or so where you also
can plug in everything we had a a model
where we uh where we had to write down
everything and this was sub-optimal and
uh did also not scale well uh across the
customer base
so this is now like the architecture how
the architecture looks like
I mentioned these influence categories
and therefore we kind of have uh here we
we said okay let's focus on three
feature types we have product features
location features and seasonal features
or calendar features
and since we want to provide also these
influence categories at the end we have
three streams that kind of uh are very
similar so uh if if I take the the
product features
for example you see that we have
categorical features like the product ID
the brand and so on
these are put into embeddings so uh and
the continuous features are more or less
uh
normalized and also cleansed for missing
values
this then
goes into an into an MLP we call this
The Meta learner
and here at the end of the meter learner
so it's just a
multi-layer perceptron
at the end of the meter learner we have
several outputs and these outputs we
call them the meter features
and this is then the pros product
specific part of our prediction
and after that we have another stage
called the connector stage
where we now combine different uh
different meta learner features so for
example if you if you consider the
seasonal feature this would be day of
week day of year stuff like this ah this
we want to combine for example here with
location
uh influences like the region the
country and so on
but instead of doing this uh on a column
basis and writing down these
interactions we now just combine the
meta features so this was done just by
concatenation the feature vectors and
then putting it into another MLP
so that's the role of the connector
and
these connectors normally have one
output
uh here the season seasonal
connector has two output but this is I
think outdated and these outputs then
compromise our factors and as you saw in
the previous slides the prediction that
we put out is the mean prediction and
the variance prediction and this is just
the sum of the logarithmic
output nodes here
and this is also what we then provide
for our customers and the UI those they
get a prediction they get a variance
bend around it and also all these
influence categories
so this is now an in an example so we
have not really a
yeah we we need really interpretability
and and as you see here we have uh an
old model that more or less is the gum
model in Orange
and the new model that's the Pew uh the
blue model and the prediction uh across
uh the time and you see here that uh in
in light or here are all these influence
categories and you see for example that
the event Factor arises here and goes
down now and and then it rises again and
goes down
and this is the prediction
um
for event for a product that never saw
Halloween or Christmas uh ever so the
model really generalized this event
effect as you see here in the upper main
plot whereas the old model did not
really learn that very well so it had
just a product group approximation of
how how Christmas looks like so the
customers can then really see okay
what's driving this prediction here in
in this time range uh it's the event
Factor so it has to do with events like
Halloween Christmas and so on and that's
what they want um they don't really want
just the black box
so in here you see a bit how the how a
meta learner can learn and automatically
since our data is is quite diverse so
you have a temperature column here a
float column
and then you have an ID column like you
would have 100 products with numbers one
to 100
we block every categorical feature into
an embedding
metrics and by the optimization so we do
a stochastic
gradient descent on Mini batches by the
optimization algorithm the information
about the sales so you see that there is
one temperature dependence that is going
down the other temperature dependence is
going up
and here you see how the model kind of
finds this out during the optimization
automatically so you don't need to
kind of guess what would be winter
products or what would be summer
products or so this is kind of done for
you
also the mapping that the ID and the
float column are important
foreign
would be our location information here
we would uh here we are looking at the
region in in Canada
so and this can then more or less what
the embedding does is uh and the meter
learner then itself it's mapping uh
mapping the um
the region information into another
space no so for the for the retail
business uh it seems that it's kind of
important to know that some sub-regions
have many coastal areas and the others
might not so it's it's more or less an
example but we can also plot these meta
features uh and and go into lower
representations
and then we see such things that um
patterns like this are learned
so now the quality of the of the new
model and the complexity so at the right
hand side you see kind of uh different
uh state-of-the-art machine learning
models
from different
yeah for for different use cases like
text processing or language model and
image models and so on and our old model
had quite a lot of parameters and we
went a bit down now uh since we are now
many more parameters in the model are
now shared so uh we don't
add an interaction for example for every
product we need a dependence to the
temperature this we we don't really do
the model finds out where this
dependence is needed
so we have lower parameters than before
the forecast accuracy is better so we
could also not find a
underfitting that more or less is
stuff that we checked with all these
time series plots that really the
effects are also described
and here in this Matrix you see on the
rows you see all other customers and in
the columns you see prediction metrics
like MSE mean deviation and mad
and you see the differences and these
are quite green which means that the the
new model was better than the old one
and this is also the procedure how we
take changes life no we do for every
customer cross validations across
several years and then measure the kpis
and look at time series plots
another funny thing we we were on the
pycon in Berlin this year
and they are the the team around Felix
week they did a hackatron to beat uh
simulated data set which is kind of like
our real retail data
and you see that we are on Place three
so without a lot of feature engineering
the cyclic boosting Master submission
was even better and also to other
candidates
but the master solution also was hand
tuned so there were interactions were
written down and a lot of pre-processing
of the data was done
whereas we kind of just ran this off the
shelf method that we have at the moment
I think the first one was the tapular
learner from open AI That's also uh
quite a powerful
and now I would hand over to Daniel
again
Thanks Martin
so
um I mean we talked about now uh how the
architecture looks like and I now come
to the challenges that we were facing
basically putting something like that
into production so to give you some
context this is the number of product
location combinations that we have for
customers so we have some customers with
several thousand but lots of customers
with several million of product location
combinations now multiplied it with
several years you come to the billions
so we have more than 300 billion rows in
the combined data set and that basically
we
as this steers The Daily Business so
about how much sell it and how much
tomatoes are in the supermarkets and
other things this is very sensitive in
not doing errors in like we cannot order
20 million tomatoes in or whatever that
the businesses could go bankrupt so we
have a quiet
dedicated quality workflow to check that
things are working fine
the first part I mean everyone has or at
least say so static code checks and test
coverage but what we have in addition
which was crucial for us is a model
exchange detection test so we have a
minimalistic data set for each of our
customers it is sufficient to detect if
any refactoring or any change steers
something that could change the model so
basically that you just want to
Performance optimize something and you
do back inside and and create a problem
so this is basically there to protect us
and get some such things
and when that layer basically succeeds
and we find okay there was a model
change or I mean normally we do that on
purpose so we change things to to go
into something
then we are going for the full model
evaluation Pipeline and the model
evaluation pipeline is run for every
customer
on a respective data set with at least
100 million rows so to say
I mean if the customer has so many
um and
um and this basically has done multiple
trainings that are time cross validated
and evaluated on multiple Horizons
because the different Horizons are
important for the different ordering
decisions that are happening afterwards
and we save everything
from prediction quality metrics and
runtime metrics into ml flow to have an
overview and can basically look on
everything at once
so the first thing that we encountered
we are basically the costs the
performance changes so basically on
start I think on started with a factor
400 or so slower but then at the end a
factor of 10 slower in training time
compared to our previous model
and then basically started using gpus
which we hadn't done so far and
basically could bring it down with 2pus
to an identical training time
we are running on Azure so basically
everything has to be booked on azure
and they are the gpus that we were using
where a factor of seven more expensive
then then the
than the CPUs and there we optimized
further in How We are booking the
training machines so like from the usage
patterns and came down so I think in the
end we were a factor 1.7 more expensive
but that was fine for the overall cost
structure as the training is not the
most critical part in that
so that one was fixed and then to the
Quality I think Martin showed the
overview graph where everything looked
green
and I also wanted to basically give a
quick overview on what we are doing so
we have multiple overview plots on all
customers
so we had these influencing categories
here on the upper right side I depict
the price change so we can basically see
how our distribution among customers
changed with different model versions
and and basically see patterns there
we have that for all the influencing
categories we have that also for um
basically all the overview kpis and in
addition we store several hundred
individual time series plots on the
individual products and locations that
we are predicting so that we can look at
the worst MSE the worst mad the worst
whatever kpi we want to have and see
okay do we find outliers do we have made
any problems with that and basically
have that saved all together so that we
can compare different model runs at once
so from a whole timeline we basically
started last of October with the initial
implementation and had done a full
visibility check around Christmas last
year
and then I think a major part where
having a feature completeness so we
basically some of the more complex
things we did not integrate in the
feasibility check like our
cannibalization model
but then added later and then the
technical challenges with the runtime
that we solved in April and we have
already gone live with the first three
customers and uh will onboard the next
until end of September so that we are
full at all the 30 customers of 32 or
whatever that we have currently
so
um what can basically be the Outlook and
the further extensions so I mean the
main goal was that we can go into
different areas because we can now
easily extend to additional data
attributes we could also integrate text
image or item data so basically also in
the direction from the previous talk how
can I integrate data sources that that
are basically available and not
structured as we Define
from input side and then we also want to
experiment on sequence to sequence
Transformer models for a further
optimization
um yeah
that's so far for the Outlook thanks for
your attention and if you if you find it
interesting you can come on in a talk
with us
[Applause]
thank you
thank you interesting talk I I have to
ask it's kind of a silly question but
did you challenge your model by going to
Australia so to the other side of the
world with the seasonality and the
location
so we try to be independent of that so
basically we get weather data from an
additional provider and we try to learn
how is the seasonal pattern and then
have have that attributed so like that's
not like winter is always in April or
what
um for Australia but but that should be
learned from the data
we're all on the Northern Hemisphere and
no one thought about it yes that's right
but that were a couple of years back we
got the first South African customer and
since then we we haven't
um
not not for all customers at once no for
privacy reasons the data is not shared
so that's one the global means that we
use all the data of One customer since
it's already quite large as you saw
maybe in the number of PL combinations
that we showed uh this before so in
cycle boosting 2013 we we did a train on
product group location
partitions more or less and had several
thousand fits than an independent models
um thanks for the talk very exciting
um how does the model handle the cold
start problem does it need a demand
history for a certain product or can it
do predictions for completely new
products like in fashion for instance if
something is completely new on the
market it can do also predictions for
completely new products I mean it's it's
more a challenge because I mean if you
have like a couple of days of sales
history you very well can anchor the the
overall pattern is it like selling five
times a day or is it selling like five
times a year a year you don't catch in
that short time frame but
um what we try and I think that's also
the main benefit of the um of the next
approach is that we learn from
additional product attributes like color
size whatever how those products might
behave and
um uh yeah and I think that's also the I
don't think we have it on the slides but
70 of the new lines that we are
predicting have improved in our metrics
for our customers so um there was a huge
benefit uh with uh introducing these
embedding layers
um for the new lines
yeah so for normal customer we integrate
historical data deliveries but if they
have Dynamic assortment that's not
really big of a problem we have a static
prediction from the machine learning
part and then once the sales kick in we
also correct in this prediction again
so thank you for the nice talk
I have a simple question maybe
it's a conceptual difference between
explainability and interpretability
of a model
I mean
I mean the explainability we need is
more or less in the output so when we
deliver the prediction to the customer
and he sees it in our UI
and then he might he might also be an
expert in his sector so he's rather he
is surprised or he says well that's a
good prediction or he says that might be
too large or why
do does the protection uh go up by a
factor of two
uh yes then normally two options rather
he believes the prediction or he puts in
a prediction override
and to do this in an educated fashion he
he can look at the demand factors and
sees okay there's a promotion going on
and the price is reduced 30
that might be uh the same order of
macrinjut that I saw in the history in
similar situations
and then for this we kind of try to
provide not only the the prediction uh
Point forecast but also these
yeah the inputs we show the customer
again the prices but also the price
factors the model learned
and and then to add your question was
very specific on this is explainable or
is it interpretable and I think
yeah yeah exactly and I I think
it
um Martin also mentioned that the main
part is that we want to group it by
input sectors of the input data so that
you know which data source has changed
and that's driving the prediction
but it's not like I mean in the end we
have like 10 categories or so so in the
end and we have like several hundred uh
influencing factors beneath so you it's
it's a simplification and it's not like
giving you the whole explanation you
have to understand much more and have to
basically look at the whole time series
to understand what's going on
yeah thanks for the talk
um related to the question of the
gentleman the white polo shirt there
have you thought about
using your model for product design
questions like if you can for instance
um predict that a new piece of fashion
in color red and
size whatever is going to sell more
often would you be able to use it for
recommending new products and their
features
so we haven't done this yet but it's I
think it's on the first side so you have
promotional planning so that would be
when you do promotions you mentioned how
would a piece of uh close sell maybe in
the next season uh it's at the moment
it's just not live there but I think the
capabilities in terms of machine
learning you would have but you could do
it in a similar way but I would then
call this a different product especially
if you have text and and image
information for close
you might be able to do that
on the other hand if you if you're
thinking about the quick fashion at the
fast fashion sector it's also not so
easy to predict I think but yeah could
could be done especially when adding
that uh that uh
that the type of I mean you have uh
usually we have for example colors as
attribute and we have like 30 000 colors
for One Customer because like they are
not normalized in any any sort of way
and they are completely different and
sizes is the same thing you have
different sizes for shoes and for
trousers and for women and for kids and
for whatever and so basically that's
really hard to combine
and there becomes very interesting for
our customers so how should they change
certain prices or certain promotions to
drive the demand to a Target that they
want to achieve and bear this
information is very important
hi thank you very much for sharing your
insights I have a question I want to
understand uh better in which context
you use your demand prediction model and
especially if you use it in the context
of a very frequent production Cycles
like for example you have a retail store
which sells Grocery and the order has to
be made day by day yes and there is a
low also like a low rate low margin
industry where the mistake is very
costly like for example again again
retail grocery sales exactly that that
that's where we are coming from so
basically that's where the solution
started and I think the key part was on
slide two with the probability density
function because I mean just I mean how
many uh how many uh what what is
perishable how many bananas you sell
tomorrow
um because you cannot keep them for as
long you need to know but if you would
only have a point estimate like five
then the optimization itself cannot be
perfect because it would be limited in
in the cost function so like the cost
for Waste is not linear and the cost for
out of stock or lost sale is not linear
and so you can much better optimize that
if you have a realistic distribution and
I think that was the key element
um back in the days and and which we are
applying every day can we really in this
fast sector so we're doing daily
predictions daily data delivery in a SAS
fashion from the customer of the sales
and uh forecasts then up to 21 days or
one year into the future and the order
Horizon of the customers might be
between 3 and 21 days where they use the
prediction yeah
then steer their order and and do you
know do you do they use a human in the
in the ordering Loop or the use they use
human less and less the faster it gets
so
because I mean sometimes they think like
okay this is six weeks out and I can I
know it better
but in the super fast business basically
there is
I mean only in exceptional cases so
sometimes things are wrong and so on but
besides that should be no human
interaction
s
to look at the predictions and then in
rehearsal and the rest circumstances
they then do prediction overrides or so
but the other end the ordering is really
automated then yes
yeah thank you very much for the talk
please give a big